this video is a bustah call to find out
more about how you can get me to do a
personalized video on a topic of your
choosing
head over to patreon.com/scishow and
line review and scroll down to the
Admiral tier but for now enjoy the video
hello and welcome to the new world
review today we are going to be entering
into the realm of my hero academia in
order to examine its cornerstone feature
works there are some pretty absurd
abilities out there in this world and
I'll be doing my best to pluck the most
outstanding to present here the main
thing I'd like to make clear is that I
will be examining the quirks themselves
trying to separate them from their users
as much as possible this is because
there are a ton of quirks in the series
that look quite overpowered but are in
reality only so because of the
tremendous ability of their users the
perfect example of this is the
permeation quirk people got absolutely
mad over this because of how they see
miryo use it but it would be a
horrendous quirk for the average person
so with that sort of thought in mind
let's begin welcome to the top 5 quirks
in my hero academia number 5 one for all
alright we'll be starting out a bit
controversially here because herp derp
deku is the main character and all might
is the greatest hero in the world but
one for all is an exceptionally
conditional power yes it can grant you
phenomenal godlike strength that you
need to be a suitable vessel to contain
it or else it will quite literally
destroy you
let's break one-for-all down a bit it's
actually a combination of two quirks one
that stockpiles power and one that makes
your quirk transferable to others that
stockpile of power is incredibly
dangerous over time admittedly a lot of
time but so much so that all might was
able to use the quirk to become the
greatest superhero in the world but he
was the eighth generation user of the
quirk so it's a tricky one to talk about
really because it would do significantly
less for you if you inherited it earlier
down the line and while it can do a lot
for you it requires a body perfectly
sculpted to use its power using this
quote is a serious lifetime commitment
to keeping yourself at the peak of human
strength and fitness it's not going to
see great use from the average person
because of the debilitating drawbacks in
fact to be perfectly honest the only
reason why one-for-all makes it onto
this list at all is because I do quite
like the idea of having an emergency
function that somebody could use to get
them out of a tight potentially
life-threatening spot even if it costs
them a limb to do so so one for all I'm
sorry the
for there are Vedic works number four
half cold half hot alright let's get
into some truly ridiculous quirks here
this ability held by Todoroki allows its
user to generate flames from the left
side of their body and ice from the
right a lot of flames and a lot of ice
from scorching hot to freezing cold one
of these elements is bound to be useful
in most situations and the sheer scale
to which a user of this quirk can
generate them all but guarantees instant
victory against the large amount of
combative opponents you could find
yourself facing the square does however
have a limit where by the user seems to
slowly lose their bodily immunity to
Fire and Ice upon extended use of either
element however by the time a user hits
that limit they most certainly should
have accomplished whatever task they
were engaged in other than that I should
mention that this quirk also requires
training to efficiently control both
elements but this quirk is simply
absolutely devastating even without that
mastery number three rewind as hinted to
in the name rewind is a quirk that
allows it to use it to turn back the
clock somewhat and in a very specific
way as the quirk is currently known
rewind is only able to affect a living
body however it is able to return that
body to a previous state up to and
including before it ever existed to
begin with so yes with this ability you
can easily just embrace a living being
from existence which very sadly did
happen
not that rewind has to be that morbid
though it could be used to erase any
injury inflicted on a person by
restoring their body to the point prior
to set injury in fact rewind is a
fantastic combination with the user of
say one for all because they can go all
out and then have rewind returned their
body to the state before they completely
destroyed it if the challenging part of
discussing this quirk is that its user
area is very young and not in complete
control of rewind making it difficult to
judge its full potential as it is now
the quirk is extraordinarily powerful
but honestly I feel like it's a bit
overrated within the fan base yes it's
amazing and that's why it's on this list
but in my mind there are still two
quirks the completely dwarfed it number
two overhaul sitting comfortably at
number two we have a quirk that allows
its user to instantly disassemble and
reassemble anything they make physical
contact with and this this is utter
madness because when I say anything I
mean anything there is no substance in
the world that will ever
stand in your way in addition to that
this is a quirk that can kill simply by
disassembling a person's body
however overhaul can also be quite a
benevolent power and can be used to
revive people so long as it occurs
quickly enough after the death so that
all chemical compounds are still intact
and able to form a fully functioning
body but overhaul can also be used to
dismantle two things and fuse them
together into a new creation this
portion of the ability can of course be
used with living beings as well to
create an entirely new body overall can
even be performed on the user themselves
in essence granting them the potential
of immortality I mean for example say
that your body starts to fail of old age
then you could just dismantle and fuse
it with another one then disassemble the
unwanted parts of your previous body
that's if you simply can't remove the
part of your body that's causing issues
in the first place like a tumor or any
other ailment like with careful use of
this quirk I don't see how you could
ever die unless it was instantaneous and
unstoppable but in any case this quirk
has limitless potential and is certainly
one of the greatest in the entire series
number one all for one this quirk is
incredibly simple in nature but it's
just too hard to go past this one the
power to forcibly transferred quirks
stands tall as the most overpowered
ability one can imagine and in the
series this essentially gets used as one
would expect from a villain to
permanently remove the quirks of others
and to absorb them into one's self as
demonstrated by all for one not to be
confused with the quirk or for one
because I guess horikoshi was just
feeling lazy with names that day but
really the basis for this being the best
quirk is simple if you see another quirk
out there that you think is better than
all for one well you just take that
quirk it's yours now Congrats but it's
not even like you traded quirks now you
just took it and after that you can do
it again with another quirk and again
and again until you've absorbed every
single quirk in the world from there a
user of all for one can combine the
acquired quirks to achieve seemingly
infinite strength and/or new abilities
and if all those quirks are too hard to
keep track of well then no worries
because you also have the option to
transfer them to other people like
perhaps say your own personal army of
quirk warriors there's just nothing to
lose by having this quirk but at the
same time there is infinity to gain all
for one is just that powerful and a
well-deserved recipient of the number
one spot on this list and that pretty
much does it for the top five quirks in
my hero academia if you in
this video then feel free do you like
favorite or subscribe and if you are in
any way inclined to support this
independent channel and feel free to
check out my patreon discord server or
Twitter the links to attorney handy
description below and finally please do
comment with your own favorite quirks in
the series this has been the New World
review and I'll see you next time